bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ce soir
sur rtl france les pourparlers se
multiplient depuis des semaines entre
moscou et les occidentaux américains
autant et européens où est-ce que ça
bloque
écoutez je pense qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment de blocage parce qu'il ya un
blocage soit lire absence de dialogue
donc à partir du moment où à tout le
monde se parle sauf bien sûr en train de
dialogue direct entre kiev et moscou et
c'est peut-être là je dirais un des
aspects du problème très intéressant
parce que ce que demande le kremlin
n'est ce pas c'est que kiev ne se
rapproche pas de l'otan et je crois que
la meilleure le meilleur interlocuteur a
évoqué dans ces cas là et bien c'est
kiev lui même a d'autant plus que la
constitution donc de l'ukraine
maintenant mentionne depuis le mois
d'octobre 2020 l'appartenance ou le
projet d'appartenir à l'otan donc il
faudrait que russes et ukrainiens puisse
parler plus directement alors justement
dans l'accélération de ces tensions
c'est aux dernières heures quelle est la
posture de kiev
la posture de kiev et de se préparer à
d'avant un éventuel conflit éventuel
mouvement de troupes russes à la
frontière ukrainienne on a aussi des
préparatifs du côté de la biélorussie
donc il y a un aspect militaire il y a
un aspect politique entre kiev et puis
bien sûr l'union européenne et les
puissances alliées autour de l'otan
acétate ap normal il y à des soldats
anglais il ya des soldats américains en
ukraine pour entraîner formé quelques
centaines à des combattants mais à des
donc des sondages destinés à former
l'armée ukrainienne
donc il y à ces dispositifs en place et
a bien sûr il faut qu'il y ait un
dialogue d'une façon ou d'une autre il
ya eu des rencontres des échanges entre
à monsieur hinse qui est la digne à
poutine il faudrait pouvoir obtenir ce
dialogue là aussi on a entendu en le
dans un rescrit le président de
l'ukraine dénoncé les propos des états
unis propos qui provoque selon lui la la
panique et n'aident pas les ukrainiens
ce sont ces mots
écoutez je crois que chacun voit un
petit peu à midi à sa porte il faut
aussi noter que la tension actuelle
alimenté bien des tensions sur les prix
des matières premières n'est ce pas
alors que à cela n'est pas tout à fait
négatifs pour la russie qui vend
beaucoup de gaz et beaucoup de pétrole
il ya au moins 10% de de prix
supplémentaires liées à la tension
géopolitique actuelle et puis pendant
qu'on regarde au delà des frontières
russes et bien on ne s'occupe pas de ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur de la russie
sur le poids économique donc il y a un
double avantage à cette crise
ukrainienne de projeter la russie en
dehors a donc sur la scène
internationale avec sa capacité
militaire et puis est bien de cacher ou
ne pas faire voir ce qui se passe
actuellement en russie ce qui peut être
difficile sur la situation sanitaire par
exemple donc il ya une ambivalence de
cette situation vous l'avez rappelé la
russie demande des garanties sur sa
sécurité sur le nom élargissement de
l'otan à l'est est ce que cette demande
est légitime à vos yeux
l'écouté toute demande est légitime et à
ce moment là comme je le disais tout à
l'heure il faut en parler avec les
premiers intéressés et c'est cette
distorsion dans le dialogue qui pose
problème parce que finalement la
thématique et est intéressante la non
appartenance ou l'appartenance de
l'ukraine à l'otan mais ce n'est pas le
bon canal n'est ce pas ou en tout cas le
canal souhaitaient peut-être par le
crème glacée de pouvoir parler d'égal à
égal avec washington d'être reconnu
comme puissance mondiale alors que il ya
une histoire fait son oeuvre n'est ce
pas il n'ya plus que 144 millions de
russes quand il y avait 300 millions de
soviétiques à d'employer les éléments de
puissance ont évolué peut-être parfois
arabe favorablement mais la russie est
toujours une grande puissance nucléaire
donc voilà il ya ce elle cette
ambivalence si vous voulez entre la
puissance d'intervention militaire et
puis les réalités économiques qui sont
pas forcément en faveur de mesures dont
une hausse et ukrainiens à la manoeuvre
visiblement les américains on vient d'en
parler il ya aussi les européens quelle
est leur posture
européen finalement on aura pu
s'attendre à ce qu'il y ait un ordre
dispersé et quand il y a une tension
alain à l'extérieur à l'extérieur d'un
cercle n'est ce pas eh bien les éléments
à l'intérieur du cercle se rapproche et
c'est ce que l'on voit actuellement au
tour donc de bruxelles c'est ce qu'on
voit aussi à l'intérieur de l'otan n'est
ce pas il y avait il ya quelques années
ou quelques oui à peu près un an et demi
deux ans il ya eu des dissonances à
l'intérieur des membres de l'otan et
bien cette fois ci il ya un discours
pratiquement unis les stars unitaire à
doc martin il ya une pression à
l'extérieur comment est ce que vous
voyez l'évolution de la situation ces
prochains jours
mais écoutez je pense qu'on devrait
aller à des échanges de propositions
maintenant pour que les propositions a
en tout cas une communication extérieure
qu'elle soit connue identifié que l'on
puisse comprendre un peu mieux aller
tenant et aboutissant de chaque partie
donc voilà ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il y
ait dans les prochains jours et bien des
discussions plus précise est évoquée à
sur la posture militaire en russie sur
la posture militaire en europe donc
vis-à-vis de l'ukraine à qu'il y ait des
éléments sur les négociations concernant
les missiles de portée intermédiaire par
exemple merci beaucoup contre regard
j'ai un respect refondateurs du
webmagazine le monde décrypté